&gt;&gt; Now that we know what parabolas look like, it's time to talk about how to
actually draw them. I mean, what you do with your hand to make them appear.
First things first, let's pick an equation to experiment with graphing with. I
want to use y equals x squared minus 2x minus 3. Just like with linear
equations, for quadratics we can use x y tables to come up with a bunch of
points that should lie on any given line or curve. In fact for quadratics, since
we're graphing these fancy curve parabolas, I find it's much easier for me if I
write down a bunch of points. When you're drawing a line, you really only need
to mark two points and then connect them together. So I'm going to use these
points to graph this curve right now. I'll of course label my axes. Here I'm
just going to use a scale of 1 for each grid mark. Wonderful. Now that I have
all of these points marked, I can start sketching a line that looks like it'll
connect all of them. I like to start at the vertex, at this lowest point in this
case, and then moved in a curved way up to the next point to the left.
Definitely takes practice to get your hand to move smoothly like you want it to,
but there, that's not too bad. Moving to the right is usually a little bit
harder for me. Takes a bit more sketching. So you can see I am doing little
strokes to make sure I'm moving my pen in the direction I really want the line
to go. Now it's a half a sort of rough sketch. I can go over it to make it
smoother. And voila, we have a parabola.